billy what do you make of when you read
bob dylan selling his catalog for like
hundreds of millions of dollars have you
ever had an appraisal done on what your
catalog would be worth if you sold it
tomorrow i've never had an appraisal
done there have been offers
for me to sell it
uh which i haven't accepted why won't
you accept it well
look for enough money i guess
everything's for sale what's that in the
godfather after all we're not
communists
right
that's right but
but
uh right now i still have control
of how these songs are used i have a say
over how they're licensed
uh if they want to be used for a
a commercial for
i don't know underarm spray or toilet
paper i can say no
but sometimes i say yes because
i i
i'm a fan of broadcast
sometimes the an advertisement will get
to more people than regular radio play
will
um
so i i'm the one who picks and chooses
how it gets used
uh and if i sell my catalog i give that
power up i give that control up and
they're my children i think of my songs
as my kids i went through a pregnancy in
a labor with these songs i remember how
hard i worked on them and i don't
necessarily want to give that permission
away
for how my kids are are
are utilized the numbers would be
astronomical well i think we're talking
a billion something dollars i mean at
least at the minimum it's worth that
much really who would pay that i don't
think so but if somebody came to me with
a billion dollars what am i going to say
no i'm from town
right